there were plenty of great games vying
for our attention in November especially
during the first half of the month
fallout 4 arrived early on a short five
months after was officially revealed at
e3 2015 while dated in some respects
thoughtful offered a dense world ripe
with complicated characters and Lord
that drew us into a society torn apart
by conflict and strife on the same day
Square Enix unleashed rise of the Tomb
Raider the follow up to 2013 impressive
reboot of the long-running series the
Tomb Raider series began its life on
PlayStation but rise of the Tomb Raider
came to Microsoft's consoles first and
to the delight of Xbox owners it proved
to be an incredible experience that
built upon the successes of the last
game delivering a focused adventure set
in a collection of beautiful and
dangerous environments tombs came back
in a big way and gave players a chance
to flex their puzzle solving skills and
relive the glory days of Lara's earliest
adventures it's the envy of PlayStation
4 owners who have to wait until this
time next year to get their boots dirty
but anyone with a gaming PC can explore
Lara's latest adventure in early 2016
blizzard close the book on the second
chapter of its exceedingly popular
realtime strategy series with the
release of starcraft 2 legacy of the
void it brings the campaign to a close
in a satisfying if canopy way with the
introduction of a new all-powerful
threat perhaps more importantly it's
tweaked how PvP matches begin that by
giving players more resource gatherers
and thus a faster start at building out
their paces a critical change that will
significantly impact competitive
Starcraft 2 players Blizzard also
introduced a new co-op mode where two
players share a single base which is the
perfect venue for new players to learn
the ropes with a capable friend by the
side of the games we reviewed in
november undertale was the most
surprising of war it's an unassuming RPG
that resembles 16-bit games like
earthbound but beneath the surface lies
an adventure filled with unexpected
twists on traditional
PG elements despite its low flying
appearance undertale substance is in
arguably modern and clever where it
matters most when reflecting on the best
games that came out in November we keep
coming back to fallout 4 but there's
this open-world RPG is a champion for
several reasons but the way it envelops
you in a grim world that reveals its
depth and beauty over time makes it a
truly memorable experience it has low
lows but also incredible highs and its
crowning achievements in crafting war
and making you feel a part of its world
mix it our selection for November's
demon the month